at yesterday's white house press
briefing jansaki claimed that there are
potentially thousands of new covid cases
in south africa therefore she said a
travel ban against several countries in
southern africa will remain in effect
one reporter from africa was in the room
he wasn't buying it
objective is i have to wrap this up in a
minute but patsy go ahead
go ahead go ahead
let patsy i just answered
it's not effective to scream over your
colleagues in here let's let's let patsy
ask a question
simon attiba is the man you just saw in
that clip he's the white house
correspondent for today news africa and
he joins us now so simon do you think
you were being disrespected by the biden
white house
thank you for having me jesse and i'm so
glad to be here and i thought fox news
were for full of racists and hate black
and hate africans but here you have me
someone who was born in africa and
covers the white house for
for today news africa
i think that the travel ban was based on
a lie
the president on november 26th banned
eight african countries
only two of those countries had any case
of omicron
variant
six of the other countries had zero case
of the variant and let me give you an
example of
namibia one of the countries the
president ban
it's a small country in southern africa
2.5 million people in two years they've
had only 400 cases of coveted 19 in the
entire country and they have zero case
zero case of the omicron variant yet the
president banned them and right now
there's total chaos because people can't
travel to namibia people can travel to
to zimbabwe people can't travel to
mozambique yet they have zero kids so i
believe that i wasn't the one who was
disrespected i think africa was
disrespected by burning countries
based on a lie
so
the biden people say the scientists told
biden to slap the travel ban on these
southern african countries and he's just
doing what the scientists want him to do
are you buying that
or do you think there's something
important
yeah it's a total lie the way people see
it in africa
the scientists i i spoke to the who
before coming here and i've attended all
the press briefing of the who in the
past two years and i've asked more
questions at the who press briefing than
any reporters in the world
and the who believed that the travel ban
don't prevent
variant
the gavi told me travel ban don't
prevent
variant from spreading
africa cdc
told me
travel ban don't prevent variant from
spreading
so uh i believe that it was a very
ill thought idea and i believe that any
scientist who says you should ban
countries that have zero variant
and allow countries that have variants
to come to the us it's it's i believe
it's a
is a bad advice and and i think that it
seems
discriminatory and it almost seems a bit
racist because all those countries all
the eight countries
uh black african countries can you
imagine if the former president donald
trump and i'm not his fan i disagree
with the street i disagree with 150
but can you imagine if he had banned
eight african countries
and those countries six of those
countries have zero k zero case of the
variant
there would have been an uprising do we
brand him a racist someone who hates
black and hates africa and and yet we
are seeing it in this administration so
i believe that africa has been
disrespected and i believe that the
travel ban
do not really make sense and any
scientist who says that you should ban a
country that has zero case
and has had 400 cases of covet 19 in two
years
and not banned the uk that had 22 cases
and i had
hundreds of thousands of people dying in
the past two years
cannot
that cannot be good science
well the theoretical situation that you
just mentioned if donald trump had done
that he would have been scorched as a
racist shows me that you simon know more
about how this country works
than a lot of the people in this country
do thanks for coming on fox news you're
always welcome we appreciate it
thank you for having me